scp-2901 also known as Mothman is a
euclid-class anomaly being pursued by
the SCP Foundation
scp-2901 is a species of nocturnal
creatures that resemble large moths with
an average height of 1.7 meters they
have insectoid bodies large eyes with
photophoric tissue and are covered in
iridescent scales similar to those of
moths
scp-2901 has the ability to manipulate
space-time allowing them to levitate fly
and teleport they also emit an acoustic
cancellation effect within a 25 meter
radius believed to assist in stealth
though the exact purpose of this ability
is unknown civilian sightings are
suppressed through a memory alteration
and media leaks are deleted or
discredited physical contact should be
avoided and objects can be used to
maintain distance despite their
abilities
scp-2901 is tangible and can be harmed
by conventional firearms